welcome back house republicans are
demanding answers from the cdc
after emails reveal a powerful teachers
union
influenced school reopening guidelines
gop leaders in the house energy and
commerce committee
they want to know if those cdc
guidelines were based on politics
and democrat campaign donations instead
of science
joining me now white house former white
house press secretary i wish she was the
current
and outnumbered co-host kaylee mcindy i
don't know that you could even defend
the policies of this administration so
not current not current i'd rather be
here with you absolutely we're happy you
are
so it's heartening to hear the
republicans want to do something about
this
they don't hold any gavels what can they
do because this feels like the kind of
thing viscerally
if unions are writing cdc guidelines i
want to know that
absolutely this is a huge scandal
unfortunately there's very little they
can do they've written a letter and
they've
put out a series of questions to the cdc
angry letter it is not that angry but it
is very fact-faced with a lot of
footnotes i did read it and one of the
things
they say is you know cdc we asked you
what stakeholders are you talking to
you left out the teachers union you
misled us and then they even go on to
say and this i thought was a very good
point of the letter
we remember wilinsky said oh you don't
need to vaccinate teachers to go back to
school and then jin sake came out and
said that's her personal opinion
they add in this letter that she had a 2
p.m conversation with the head of
the teachers union before changing her
opinion
very fact-based letter i agree with you
though i want to know more about it
a is that omission an oversight is there
any way to know whether it's an
oversight or they're like listen we
can't list the fact that we talk to the
teachers unions about this
yeah i don't think it's an oversight i
think that it is a direct omission
they can't say that they talk to them
they know that there will be foia
requests and this will all be exposed
and it was
interesting hopefully we get more uh
you've had some famous exchanges with an
anchor over at cnn chris cuomo
uh he said something last night that we
want to get your reaction to listen to
this
donuts beer businesses i think you and i
we call for a table
it's going to be mobbed where we live
wait we're both vaccinated i think we
should get a preference
i'm fine with it of course he's fine
with it
he's vaccinated he should get a
preference tip this is the same guy that
used his connections to his brother
governor
to get tested earlier than the common
folk he also had this sort of fake
quarantine in his own basement what
universe does chris cuomo live in
uh his own uh he wants preference with
his buddy don lemon they have these
nightly exchanges that are really
bizarre i would encourage no one to
watch them
uh but not only nobody does not only did
he get preference and testing i was
reading the details of this today this
is
nuts state troopers brought him the
testing a physician
in fact tested him the physician that
was supposed to be in charge of getting
coveted testing to nursing homes
instead spending hours getting kova
testing to chris cuomo
where a state trooper would then deliver
it and the nurses said they recall being
like they're coming they're coming get
ready
you know we've got to get these samples
processed quickly this is galling he
deserves no
preference in restaurants testing or
anything else but he'll get it because
of his brother well what is the what is
the sentiment that says
i deserve prefer i'm superior i'm the
kinda and you can read too deeply into
something like this that's probably not
completely what he means but the
totality of the types of statements he
makes
leads you believe that's the idea it's
like i can get away with whatever i want
well look who he's related to andrew
cuomo who has his staff
his staff in the new york state
government writing his book
getting a book deal while killing
seniors in nursing homes this is his
brother this is who he's related to
they have big egomaniac problems there's
no doubt about it because otherwise you
wouldn't make a statement like that no
you would not and by the way i will i
have to mention this the collapse of
cuomo is on fox nation right now if you
want to get a sense of the type of ego
that drives andrew and chris it's all
there a lot of episodes
and kudos to fox news channel for
running that commercial during his show
on cnn
that's what you got to do kudos kayla
you're the best thank you hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else